the filmmakers behind Joker have been
clear that they never intended to adapt
a specific comic with the movie now that
we can all see the film for ourselves
it's obvious they meant it
here are some of the biggest ways the
Joker of Joker is different from the
comics spoilers ahead throughout Joker
arthur fleck undoubtably lives in a
world of fantasy as he's watching the
late-night talk show with his mother
arthur imagines himself in the audience
eventually being called up to the stage
by host Marie Franklin he has an
imaginary relationship with his neighbor
Sophie thinking she's in love with him
when she barely remembers his name these
fantasies call every event in the film
into question making it easy to argue
that the movie's climactic scenes are
also a kind of fantasy it's possible to
interpret most of the film as simply
flecks imagination and that has always
been a patient at the mental institution
we find him in at the end while the
Joker of the comics is certainly no less
prone to delusion we're not seeing DC
Comics solely from his point of view
Joker is not just a violent fantasy he's
real and his actions have consequences
well the Joker movie teases the
possibility of the plot being a grand
illusion of Arthur's the Joker of the
comics is a problem for everybody
one of the more predictable events at
the end of Joker is the slaying of Bruce
Wayne's parents as Gotham erupts in
violence the Wayne's emerged from a
theater showing 1981 Zorro the gay blade
and Thomas Wayne steers them down an
alleyway in hopes of avoiding the riots
unfortunately one of the clown mask
wearing rioters spots the family and
follows them he calls out to Thomas
Wayne and tells him he's going to give
him what he deserves
he kills the couple yanking off Martha
Wayne's pearl necklace in the process
and leaves the young Bruce Wayne
helpless with his parents corpses it's
possible you've seen all of this before
[Music]
stop
don't go in there even if we assume that
we are meant to believe the events of
the scene actually do take place and
aren't a part 2 flex imagination it
diverges significantly from the comic
books lanes of the Wayne's when Joe
Chill kills Thomas and Martha Wayne in
the comics there's no overt political or
social uprising at work he doesn't wear
a clown mask and their deaths have
nothing to do with the Joker who won't
show up until nineteen forties Batman
number one after the Wayne's have been
dead for years and Bruce Wayne has
already been crime-fighting for a bit
the depiction of their killing that we
see in Joker is perhaps most similar to
how it unfolds in 1989's Batman and that
earlier film it's Jack Napier the movies
Joker who proves to be the Wayne's
sister we have no idea what the given
name is of the Joker of the comics while
it's revealed to be Arthur Fleck - Joker
and Jack Napier in 1989's Batman in the
comics Joker has no legal ID we don't
know if anyone knows his given name we
don't even know Joker himself remembers
assuming he even has one some comics
have suggested that there's an undefined
supernatural element to the Joker and
that he's been alive in Gotham for
centuries the closest thing Joker has to
an origin story is in the 1988 graphic
novel Batman The Killing Joke where we
see flashbacks of Joker as a failing
stand-up comic who's lured into a single
night of crime to help support his young
wife and their unborn child and it's
that same night that finds him
plummeting into a vat of chemicals that
changes his life forever yet even in The
Killing Joke we never learned the
characters given name not even his first
name as much as he hates his name Arthur
Fleck should arguably feel lucky he even
gets to have one as much as todd
phillips since this joker isn't an
adaptation from any comic the story
takes at least partial inspiration from
The Killing Joke in the graphic novel we
catch glimpses of a possible origin
story and flashbacks as Joker works on
his latest scheme but even The Killing
Joke is very different from what we see
in Joker and we all know Joker prefers
his backstory to be multiple choice you
know it's funny this reminds me of the
joke in The Killing Joke the young Joker
is a wannabe stand-up comic who like
Arthur Fleck can't get audiences to
laugh
unlike Fleck the young Joker of The
Killing Joke doesn't make up any
fantasies that replaces audiences
silenced with laughter he is painfully
aware that he's a failure and with his
wife expecting a bay
he agrees to join a group of crooks and
robbing a chemical factory
it's the robbery that leads to the
comics fall into a chemical vats and his
subsequent transformation into the Joker
on the surface at least the fact that
both early versions of the Joker are
stand-up comics who aren't any good at
comedy is where their similarities end
Arthur Fleck doesn't have an unborn
child on the way the only crimes he
commits are the ones he wants to commit
he doesn't let any mobsters strong-armed
him into it and he has nothing to do
with the Red Hood the Elliots The
Killing Joke Siong comic uses before his
fateful transformation the scenes in
Joker of Arthur Fleck putting on his
makeup are some of the most quietly
chilling in the film whether he's
forcing a smile onto his face so hard he
tears up from it or spreading the makeup
onto his tongue but the Joker of the
comics doesn't wear makeup unless he's
trying to look normal
there is no definitive word on how it
happens but the artificial and
clown-like attributes of the Joker the
bone white skin the green hair etc are
all typically permanent well and Batman
number one Joker does wear makeup but
later origins retcon that out in Batman
The Killing Joke we get glimpses of an
origin story that shows Joker falling
into a vat of chemicals in fact earlier
in the graphic novel the fact that Joker
doesn't wear makeup is what lets Batman
know the villain has escaped Arkham
Asylum he visits the facility to talk to
Joker but figures out Joker's escaped
when he grabs the man he believes to be
the criminal by the wrists and white
makeup comes off on his glove Joker's
origin story and The Killing Joke isn't
considered to be set in stone but
regardless his skin face and hair will
take more than a shower to make it look
like Arthur flex we don't see much of
Arkham State Hospital and Joker
Arthur visits it to get the file
chronicling his mother's stay there from
what little we see of the facility it's
easy to spot fairly huge differences
between its and its comic book
counterparts the Arkham Asylum of the
comics is a crazy mix between Gothic
architecture and space-age security
designed to hold killer clowns and half
crocodile cannibals it's usually
depicted as being outside Gotham City
proper behind intimidating wrought iron
gates the guards are usually carrying
enough high-tech stuff to hold Darth
Vader off for a few minutes yet somehow
Riddler and Joker and everyone else
constantly escape regardless the Arkham
State Hospital of Joker is anchored more
securely in the real world
Arthur gets there by bus and it appears
to be somewhere in Gotham City as
opposed to the outskirts the interior
doesn't look any more high-tech than
what you'd expect in a 1980s hospital
and when he goes to get the records for
his mom Arthur appears to be in the same
halls as some of the patients none of
whom are behind electrified bars guarded
by guys with more weapons than Judge
Dredd when penny Blake tells Arthur he's
the son of the famous Thomas Wayne he
goes to Wayne Manor to confront his
father instead he entertains the young
Bruce Wayne with magic tricks and comes
close to choking Alfred Pennyworth
proclaiming his mother is delusional
Thomas Wayne tells Fleck the same thing
when Arthur corners him in a theater
restroom and Arthur's convinced his
mother sold him a fantasy when he steals
Penny's records from Arkham State
Hospital the file includes Arthur's
adoption paperwork and newspaper
clippings about his abuse at Penny's
boyfriend's hands the question is never
completely settled
Arthur later finds a photo of his mother
as a young woman with I love your smile
written on the back and signed with the
initials TW with Thomas Wayne's wealth
and influence the notion that he could
falsify records to erase the stain of
his mistresses child isn't out of the
question
in the comics the notion that Joker and
Batman are blood related in any way
isn't a thing though the question of
Bruce Wayne having a brother he doesn't
know about has arisen in recent years as
part of DC Comics new 52 reboot the
court of owls storyline and Batman
includes Lincoln March a mayoral
candidate who claims to have been born
as Thomas Wayne jr. but Batman refuses
to believe him toward the end of Joker
Arthur's former co-workers Randall and
Gary show up at his apartment offering
spirits and companionship after his
mother's death when it becomes clear
Randall is only there to fish for info
on the subway killings Arthur brutally
kills the old clown with a pair of
scissors
Gary cowers in the corner sure he's next
but Arthur lets him go telling him he's
the only one at paja that was ever nice
to him the comic book Joker has grown
exceedingly cruel and ruthless over the
years and leaving survivors behind isn't
one of his hobbies the fact that Gary
has pure intentions when visiting Arthur
or treated him nice wouldn't change his
fate if anything the fact that Gary had
every reason to expect mercy would serve
as more incentive for the comic book
Joker to kill him because it would make
the whole thing funnier in his twisted
mind perhaps one of the more obvious
ways Joker's Arthur black differs from
his comic book counterpart
his lack of killer gadgets no acid
shooting the pail flowers and no
electric cutting hand buzzers the Joker
of the comics is so heavily armed with
the stop he's essentially a walking
booby trap
but Arthur Fleck uses no weapons more
creative than a gun a pair of scissors
and a pillow
[Music]
of course this makes sense
Arthur Fleck isn't in a world with
batman-themed vigilantes or legions of
Doom at least not yet
Joker is much more grounded in the real
world than most Batman films and filling
it with deadly gift-wrapped bombs or
pistols that shoot bang flags wouldn't
fit the closest thing that gadgets we
see Arthur use are is perfectly
non-lethal clown props like the wand he
uses to entertain the young Bruce Wayne
look closely after he gets beaten up by
teenagers in the beginning of Joker and
you can see the water draining from his
lapel flower onto the concrete giving
the impression it's just as precious to
the clown is blood in the comics it's
always either Batman or one of his
costumed allies who brings the Joker to
justice the less super law enforcement
of gotham really can't challenge him
what is that a bazooka
even when Batman catches the clown he's
destined to escape but at the very least
to take someone with a mass to give
Gotham a break from Joker for a couple
of days such is not the case in Joker
in fact the Arthur Fleck of Joker not
only doesn't seem all that tough to
apprehend he doesn't seem particularly
concerned with being caught after he
kills Murray Franklin he apparently just
hangs around the studio until the police
come for him because the next time we
see him he's being driven away in the
back of a police cruiser
so while the Gotham City of Joker
certainly could use some help with its
garbage strike and it's impoverished
citizens they seem to be able to catch
Joker without any costumed crime
fighters help in this version of the
story Gotham needs Civic reforms way
more than they need to do dress like a
bat who drop kicks muggers check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book villains are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]